if you have hepatitis A or B your liver
is inflamed because you have been
infected with either the hepatitis A
virus or the hepatitis B virus
your liver is a soft flexible organ that
performs many important functions
the functional parts of your liver are
called hepatic lobules
your hepatic lobules filter all of the
blood in your body
as the blood passes through your hepatic
lobules breakdown harmful substances
remove bacteria and worn out blood cells
and forms clotting factors that
controlled leading
after a meal your liver stores nutrients
to provide your body with energy when
needed your liver also makes a substance
called bile your gallbladder stores bile
and releases it into your small
intestine to help digest fats in the
food you eat if you have hepatitis A the
virus entered your body when you were
exposed to fecal matter from a person
infected with the virus you may have
been exposed to the virus by eating
contaminated food or water contact with
infected feces such as during a diaper
change or having unprotected sex with a
person infected with the virus if you
have hepatitis B the virus entered your
body when you are exposed to the blood
or other body fluids from a person
infected with the virus
this could have happened from sharing a
drug syringe with an infected person
other ways you may have been exposed to
the virus include having sex with
someone infected by the virus sharing
personal hygiene items such as razors or
toothbrushes used by an infected person
direct contact with the blood or body
fluids of an infected person or when a
mother passes it to her baby during
birth
when either the hepatitis A or B virus
enters your liver it invades your liver
cells
and makes copies of itself
in response your body sends immune cells
to attack both the virus and liver cells
infected with the virus as a result
these liver cells become inflamed and
then die
time scar tissue forms around dead and
infected liver cells which prevents your
liver from working properly
if you have a chronic hepatitis B
infection your liver contains a large
amount of scar tissue called cirrhosis
which limits blood flow and result in
permanent shrinking and hardening of
your liver
if you have hepatitis A your doctor
won't prescribe any medical treatment
because your immune cells will
eventually find and destroy all of the
hepatitis A viruses in your body
if you have hepatitis B your immune
system will usually remove all the
hepatitis B viruses from your body
in some people with chronic hepatitis B
particularly children their immune cells
are unable to remove all of the
hepatitis B viruses
if you have chronic hepatitis B and your
immune system can't get rid of the virus
completely your doctor may prescribe
antiviral medication
if you have a severe case of chronic
hepatitis B your doctor may recommend a
liver transplant operation